[Music]
joe
you have an assistant currently correct
kind of not really but why kind of not
really how about you bart no i need one
no how about you tim i've never had a
missus i'm getting a new one i do have
one that worked i
do not my brother has been our assistant
before [ __ ] you're right yeah i am so
sorry
[ __ ] sakes jesus i'm getting a new one
i'm hiring a new one you are yeah
and in this hiring process how are you
hiring them i have a manager that's
hiring them
and what do they do do they post up like
a like a like a job description thingy
yeah yeah no he he he sends out the word
is anybody looking for a job in l.a
verbally then yeah
word of mouth word of mouth i only take
in people who know people
well this story here it's
it's pretty interesting so because what
happened
because there is this job
posting listing on this
entertainmentcareers.net
website and it's this youtuber
a well-known celebrity slash influ
influencer with 10 plus million
followers oh [ __ ]
from youtube posted a part-time
job sting on that website looking for a
personal assistant preferably for free
practical i saw this please work for
free practically like a dollar an hour
no no okay so this is the listing it's
this long
with this but i'll read it it's intense
they don't know how to like space it
here we go it says
and it's quite long okay i'll try to
read it as fast as i can okay go
okay it's it's part-time job for
professional personal assistant to large
celebrity
a well-known celebrity influencer slash
influencer with 10 plus million
followers is seeking a well-organized
available slash diligent personal
assistant to join her team
this is a part-time personal assistant
position
but it will eventually transition to
full-time if properly qualified
the ideal candidate will be responsible
for a large range of activities and
projects which will assist the
organization this organization's
leadership in this position you should
feel comfortable planning slash managing
calendar activities being on property
around eight hours a day
cleaning cooking communicating with
producers slash
videographer slash editor slash manager
all stylist slash cleaning service slash
other celebrities
slash friends researching and preparing
for all production production
and post production activities handling
all personal tasks for the youtuber etc
you must be able to remain
calm rational and hardworking at all
times you will have to answer
oh no it's superwoman isn't it she said
hardworking
you will have to answer your phone slash
be on call almost 24 7.
you must keep all emotion private life
matters completely away from
this world you will deal with lots of
incredibly private matters
you must be able to handle hundreds of
small tasks at once
you must be able to be the bad guy
remove emotion
handle intense conversations and bounce
back instantly from any mistakes without
emotion
you must remain a lot of emphasis on no
emotions
right you must remain sober yet social
and inviting
in very high profile environments you
cannot
take photos post to social media or b
seem driven by fame once the kovid 19
pandemic is over you will be
you must be willing to travel anywhere
at any time
okay now it gets into this list
compensation
hourly 25 to 30 dollars an hour there
will be that's pretty good
for overtime slash full day rates for
travel
responsibility schedule plan and prepare
all filming editing posting from
pre-production posts but
we already talked about that uh what
else manage
all incoming outcome outgoing
communications that are assigned to you
schedule and assist with travel
including talking to the client meetings
organize and unpack
pack and unpack clients bags constantly
researching
and communicating with brands
sponsorships commission available
question mark
all personal day to day tasks must live
40 to 60 minutes away from los angeles
must have a car and will be able to
drive
why are they blissing out basics
pretty basics what it doesn't make any
sense to me there's also a question mark
fluent in english i no longer think it's
super woman because
she only said hard working one time and
superwoman says she works hard a lot
more than that there's a lot of question
marks in this list though because it's
like question mark fluid in english
question mark ability to handle multiple
tasks while staying organized question
mark
if they have 20 to 30 bucks an hour
there are professional personal
assistants that that has
experience and like and it's like it
sounds like they're recruiting
an amateur that's never done personal
assistant before
so they have to list out all of these
basic things that i'm just like
a person that's done this before they
already know like
seventy percent of the [ __ ] that they're
listing yeah must know how to use the
pump at a gas station
yeah yeah exactly like it's like not be
a fang boy
when people around like that's a given
so it sounds like they're
trying to reach out to their fan boys
and girls yeah i think so
who can well because like with all these
specifications it's like they're being
like
that's what they're they're throwing it
out to all their fans right and being
like but
can you not be a fan and actually be
like loyal and help me
they put it on uh
entertainmentcareers.net isn't that like
a legit
oh did they they also didn't name who
the
person was yeah i kind of think that
they had a bad
experience with like previous hires so
they had to
make sure that all these things are
covered but i kind of feel like they're
that's obvious it's a given right like
if you're
a personal assistant to a celebrity
regardless if they're a youtuber or
whatever
you're not supposed to try to ask for
pictures
yeah if a celebrity comes in and all
this stuff like that's hella
unprofessional
i also think maybe because of the covid
times the interviewing process is
different
it's like i can see where you put a
basic post up and these are things that
you brief them about
you know like almost like if you watch
like devil wears prada right as she's
going into the building
you don't do this you don't do this you
don't do this you don't do this because
this is what this person wants so you
list all these things but since you
don't have a chance to
meet each interviewee in person they're
like how can i filter
everyone out in a massive way first
right
and i'll just i'm gonna try to scare you
away and out of the people that aren't
scared i'm up for the job
cool yes so i don't know that's me
playing devil's like i don't know hey
but it sounds like like you said like it
sounds like there's some trauma
like must not walk up to a table when
i'm with my friends and drop all your
head shots all over the place and be
like oh my god
i know it's so specific please whatever
you do do not bring your own business
cards and try to get followers on your
instagram while you're there and ask for
collaborations
with others don't start seeing a
monologue in the middle of my party
it's interesting that they emphasize no
emotions like three times
a lot of times yeah 20 times and then
also people were pointing
out they're like picking up oh so this
is supposed to post it on twitter and
then like i'm looking at the replies on
twitter and they're like
25 to 30 an hour 24
7 on call 365.
i guess it adds up yeah that's pretty
good actually it's pretty damn good
part time gig that's being an assistant
though that's eight hours a day though
so eight hours a day in in her home but
24 hour 24 7 on call like that
and then they're they're pretty much
making it seem like the people
reading this are like so if i take a
call at home
like that doesn't count as me working
because they're not gonna be getting
paid during that time no no on call is
like if i need you you're gonna you're
come you're coming right there no yeah
no but i'm saying like as they're taking
the calls at home and they're at home
because they made it it seemed to be a
point that it's like well when you're
there
because doctors are on call they're not
oh true yeah working all the time but if
they get a page and it's 3am they have
to get up and go to the hospital
yeah but they're not working 24 7.
they're not like you know
you can still have a life yeah and then
they also wrote in here actual work days
will be flexible but generally
expect to be with the client at all
times
minimal days off sounds about right i
mean that this is pretty
like my i had an ex-girlfriend who used
to
personal assist like this nice
couple who worked in hollywood and it's
pretty that's pretty much how it was
it was a miserable life for her for sure
because like you're their slave
basically right
but yeah and the weight asks standard
though yeah seems standard but the way
that they i will say the way that they
treat you especially if you're a quote
nanny or a
assistant is like it's like it's like
you're a
lower class and you're expected to like
go hang out with the lower class people
when they all hang out with each other
like you're supposed to hang out with
the others
yeah you can't hang out with them and
have conversations
like i think that's the the level of
professionalism like it's like this like
personal assistant your staff of the
house
like the butler like the maid like the
groundskeeper like all that right so
what
people might not understand is like when
you're a butler
to the home right you're you're not
going to
go in and sit down at the table and be
like bro you know what happened today
yeah yeah yeah you know yes yeah like so
like
because you're the butler to the home
and by the way joe is hiring right now
well for for example um when people have
personal
uh assistance too they usually have a
team
yes uh you so so when you're when you're
working with a team
you might have three people four people
who knows right
and they're all getting paid like pretty
good but you could make it we want
multiple
personal assistants yeah for different
tasks too yeah
but there is a a a a tryout phase
where typically what they do is they
need to check
if you can actually do the job
and because it's it's not personal
assisting is not like
you get a degree you become an engineer
and then like
you you you know you get job references
or whatever and then like you you know
how to like
do this task that's um
kind of taught to you through school
it's custom
tailored how resourceful can you be how
is your timing how
street smarts yeah how can i beat tim's
brain so he doesn't have to run this
errand
so like if i'm assisting for tiff tim
right to be like
um hey i gotta get a covet test
figure it out yeah he's not going to
tell you how to do it right he's going
to tell what he wants
okay well [ __ ] uh let me get some
options let me call a pharmacy
uh do you want to do a home test i'm not
going to keep bothering him and being
like hey tim
this and this you get all those things
down you go all right tim here's your
three options
you could take one at home you could
take one and you could go to the dodgers
stadium you can do this whatever
and then tim throw that away i need a
cobia test
figure it out i love it exactly i love
it yeah so another reply to this twitter
thread was
part time is less than 32 hours that's
equivalent to working four days at eight
hours
per day which they put in the ad right
like eight hours a day at the home
and they said yet this influencer wants
someone there 24 7 or like with someone
available capable of
phone call and then they said i have a
feeling the person will also be
violating labor laws and break
and breaks and lunch hours almost all
jobs and entertainment violate labor
relations
well there are cases too where you go
like for example if you're an assistant
you'll do an hour work you go home and
then you're not
with them whatever and then like you get
called in
three hours later i mean there's so much
i mean you you assisted for me bart
david whatever yeah so i
[ __ ] rapped both like i'll i'll see
you guys
at the same time so i had like scheduled
days like okay
on wednesday i do everything that
whatever
bart needs me to do or like on monday
it's joe or whatever it was i don't
remember
yeah a little assistant yeah i was an
assistant ho actually i would
but she was able to manage three people
like
and help them out part-time and so
like i think also you guys were super
easy
bosses by the way i have to mention well
over here
yeah oh damn what was it was kind of
intense
i thought i was easy too no like but
yeah i mean it was manageable
right but then the way that they're
writing it yeah it sounds
pretty demanding yeah but some people
are just [ __ ] demanding people
so from my experience i feel like
a lot of this stuff is easy to do
but there are people out there that are
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and you do not want to work for them
well also too like bart was saying
i mean i remember being a job interview
and standard thing for job interviews my
dad
owned a business for a long time and is
to scare the [ __ ] out of the person so
that you know you're hiring somebody who
can handle
a day true at your job so like i knew
that when they were trying to [ __ ]
scare me
for my first job being hired like i was
like sure whatever i don't care
like you know what i mean like i was
like i'll just come in i'll do exactly
what you do i won't [ __ ] around the
internet all the things you're worried
about i won't do and they're like
he's hired immediately true because
there's a lot of slackers
like if you own a business or you know
that there's a lot of people that just
want an easy gig they want to collect a
check and do the least amount of work
and you want to scare all those people
away if you read this and you do get
scared if you read this and you're like
man this is really hard
it's just it's not for them yeah they're
not looking for you people are picking
it apart though like
because there was still a lot more that
i didn't read like for example this one
was like
remain so sober but social people are
like
what does that mean right like you i
want you to smoke weed with everyone but
you better not do it on your own you
[ __ ]
drug addict don't be a the weirdo in the
room though i know what they mean
because there are there are weird it is
too much though dude like if you're that
paranoid don't even hire anybody it
sounds like if they're going to be
micromanaging yeah
shut the [ __ ] up and just get a
professional it does song
like this other one says i love the
question marks like because remember i
mentioned yeah
yeah they said i also love how an
assistant is supposed to help with
social media management analytics video
production scheduling wardrobe
management sponsorship management
for 50k a year in la that is
well assistant that you end up doing
everything well the word
sounds fancy but it's literally like let
me post a picture and
type in a caption and say hey is this
caption okay okay cool take my picture
and post it
yeah depending on how big this person is
this might not even be the person's post
this could be their head assistance
looking for other assistants and that
the head assistant is like i'm tired of
dealing with people that i can't count
on
so my team needs to you know like the
person that's actually
right might not even be dealing with
this book yeah
the part that kind of stuck out to me is
something that sounds crazy is like the
being in charge of video production part
and i was like you know you know because
getting [ __ ] together for a video can be
a lot
yeah and you gotta know your [ __ ] like
you gotta know like that's a protect the
hierarchy
right yeah the how how how video uh
shoot is supposed to go yeah it's the
whole job
and maybe this person's video production
is this true
i thought i was gonna say it's true that
happens too i'm gonna say
what if it but if this person's like a
popular like mukbanger and the video
production is like go get the [ __ ]
shake shack for me all right how many
tubers do we know
that call what they do video production
right and like yeah like you said they
put that on a little tripod that's like
this big
sure because i i used to intern for a
commercial company
and like some of the things that they
they had me do was to cold call
uh rental houses and stuff to ask for
equipment
equipment i've never even heard of and i
have to like google and figure out what
it is and like things like that and it
doesn't seem like
this is the type of job that's going to
require them to be figuring out like
locations and talking to like location
managers and then asking for permits and
i'm like
did you get paid hourly no it's for free
this is before the big labor law [ __ ]
gonna ask you like how much did you get
paid
i did for three months for free two days
a week i had a buddy that was assistant
to a general in iraq
yeah and uh that's not even his job but
the generals i need a [ __ ] assistant
and you you're my assistant now
and then he's like uh i have another
general friend that's coming to visit me
in his like tent he goes i need you to
find me a queen-sized mattress
wow he's sleeping on a mattress and he's
like where the [ __ ] do i find a mattress
in a war zone
oh god but he had to [ __ ] one out yeah
make it [ __ ] happen you have to make
your [ __ ] he's like can i use
saddam's gold please
no stop saying can i use saddam's gold
we can't use it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]